march madness is nearly here and
opportunity village has a fun contest
coming up just to
enjoy the basketball and of course help
a great local organization it's
opportunity village
joining us now to talk about this
director of development for ov greg
gutenkov is joining us this morning greg
good to see you this morning how you
doing good morning john doing wonderful
thank you
all right so tell us more about hoopla
so pixro v hoops hoopla is uh sponsored
by nutrishop
and we figured millions of people fill
out brackets each year for the ncaa
tournament
why not do so to support the programs
and services we have at opportunity
village and impact the lives of people
with diverse abilities
you know opportunity village we've
highlighted so much here in town
it does such great work here how does
this work if people want to get involved
in this
i know i'm going to be taking part our
friend ron futrell here at channel 8
he's i think committed to taking part as
well how does this work how can people
get involved
so people can register at pix4ov.com
and for a 50 donation you get entry into
the contest
um we believe you know again it's a fun
way to support the people that we serve
there's prizes for the top five and
again you get to compete against local
celebrities
you beat me to the punch but i was going
to say even certain news anchors
i know certain news anchors that have
absolutely no concept of college
basketball that would be me
let's talk greg if we can also just
about what it's been like at opportunity
village
through the pandemic i know we we
profiled ov in the beginning of the
pandemic when things had to shut down
some of the operations for the clients
and so forth
where do things stand now and just how
has the uh the charity been able to sort
of push through
uh thank you for mentioning that you
know i mean we're blessed to be able to
continue to move
uh folks back onto campus and continue
to engage with them in other ways
uh march is actually developmental
disabilities awareness month and the
theme is moving towards change and some
of the things that we've been
highlighting
have been the ways that obi has stayed
connected uh to the people that we serve
throughout the pandemic and so
uh pivots have included in-home services
for some of the most vulnerable people
that we serve
a shift to virtual job training
and even connecting caregivers to
resources out in the community
it's so important as you well know for
people who for the people that you serve
to stay connected to keep that community
intact so that there isn't isolation
just to keep that
vibrance around because it is so uh so
helpful to be sure
let's once again talk about the contest
again if there's people want to sign up
again where do they sign up and what's
the deadline
yes so uh it's pixerov.com
and the deadline is uh to sign up is 7
a.m
uh march 19th so when the brackets are
released on the 14th
uh we'll send out an email to those
folks that have signed up uh all giving
you all the rules and how to
fill out your bracket and then up until
that time on the 19th
we'll be getting ready to go and then
we'll be excited for tip-off it's always
fun to do the brackets it's even better
to do it for a great organization
great thanks for joining us this morning
good luck and i'll get my brackets
sorted out as soon as i can i promise
thank you for the time of course thank
you